A former model and Miss Israel winner, actress
Gal Gadot has always been lean and mean.
In order to play the title character in Warner
Bros.'s Wonder Woman, Gadot had to make her
body a little less lean, and a whole lot meaner.
Making the leap from model to superhero is
no easy feat, but here's how Gal Gadot got
in shape to play Wonder Woman.
Real life warrior
It's well known that Gadot represented her
home country of Israel in the 2004 Miss Universe
pageant.
Less well known, however, is the fact that
as an Israeli citizen, Gadot also served a
compulsory two-year term of service in the
nation's military.
But she didn't merely scrape through and serve
her time — Gadot dominated the intensive
three-month military boot camp and earned
herself a spot as a combat trainer.
Even still, Gadot said that her training for
Wonder Woman was actually even more difficult
than training for the army.
"Do you think being in the Israeli army helped
you with your training?"
"Um, it was a lot more intensive."
She loves sports
Physical fitness is a lifelong passion for
Gadot, who learned to swim when she was four.
Growing up, she spent 12 years training as
a dancer, while also playing tennis, basketball,
and volleyball.
She told ESPNW that she's highly competitive
and that she always plays to win — "otherwise,
why bother, right?"
In her spare time, she also indulges in rock
climbing, all while taking care of her two
young daughters.
Now there's a real Wonder Woman.
Diet of the gods
It may be hard to believe, but Gadot actually
didn't go on an insane diet to achieve her
superhuman fitness level.
Instead, she simply practiced moderation and
common sense, using the tried and true method
of mixing greens with lean proteins to get
the most out of her workouts.
She also kept hydrating, drinking a gallon
of water each day.
But she told Harper's Bazaar that she more
or less ate what she wanted, when she wanted,
and was able to get away with it because she
respected her body's needs.
"I look at food as fuel and I want to give
the best to my body.
It's all a matter of measurements and quantity
of the food; just enjoy your food and don't
eat while you drive and don't eat when you
talk on the phone.
Just give the food the respect and give yourself
the respect to enjoy it."
A beast in the gym
In order to prepare for the role of Wonder
Woman, Gadot spent months working with professional
trainers.
When she started, she couldn't execute a single
pull-up.
But by the end she was ripping through a daily
routine that included rowing machines, stationary
bikes, broad jumps, crab walks, pull-ups,
push-ups, squats, ball exercises, and weightlifting.
She may use a sword and a lasso in the film,
but there's no question that she can bust
out the gun show whenever she wants.
No cheat days
When you're a superhero, you don't get any
days off.
After all, the world isn't going to save itself.
That's why Gadot trained "six or seven hours
a day" every single day for half a year.
And that training wasn't confined to the gym
alone.
She also had to undergo ultra-intense weapons
training to learn how to properly use a sword
and shield.
But the most difficult part of her training?
Surprisingly, it was horseback riding.
She explained it all in an Australian news
interview, "I also thought I was going to
love horse riding because it always looked
as if it’d be so easy.
It’s not.
It was super painful and I had tons of bruises.”
She defeated Conan
Ever wonder what might happen if Wonder Woman
battled Conan?
Well, we learned the answer during Gadot's
promotional tour for Wonder Woman.
Except it wasn't Conan the Barbarian she faced
off against — it was Conan O'Brien.
Claiming he would accomplish in 35 minutes
what took Gadot months and months of everyday
training, Conan O'Brien bragged about his
three months of Girl Scouts service before
Gadot and her trainer critiqued his less than
heroic physique.
Afterwards, Gadot showed off her powerful
high kicks before battling the comedian in
a swordfight.
*grunting*
If there's one thing to take away from this
segment, it's that Gal Gadot can not only
dominate with her high kicks and physical
prowess, but also slay with her stunning good
looks, personality and charm.
She's a wonder, that Wonder Woman.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!